un giorno di tanti anni fa passeggiando
per le strade di bologna mi sono
imbattuta in una frase scritta sul muro
non c'è lotta senza balotta allora per
voi che siete qui non c'è bisogno di
traduzione ma per tutti gli altri in
italiano potremmo dire non c'è lotta
senza divertimento non c'è lotta senza
un gruppo di amici con cui ci si diverte
ed è proprio da questa frase che voglio
cominciare oggi a parlarvi di
cittadinanza mobile di cittadinanza
globale perché nella mia esperienza
tutto è cominciato proprio da molto
divertimento e da tanti amici
correva infatti l'anno 2000 e come tanti
della mia generazione mi apprestavo a
partire per uno scambio erasmus allora
non lo sapevo ancora ma sarei partita
una seconda una terza una quarta volta e
avrai finito per stabilirmi all'estero
allora non lo sapevo ancora e quindi
molto emozionata organizzato delle feste
a casa dei miei genitori chiamando tutti
i miei amici per gli ultimi saluti e poi
vedete due cartelloni delle prime due
feste mc in paris e io parto parti di
cui vado particolarmente fiero e zeppe
di disegnini e parole di incoraggiamento
dei miei amici ora già la terza volta mi
sarei sentita francamente un po ridicola
a mettere un cartellone perché
l'esperienza del viaggio stava
diventando qualcosa di ordinario
quello che invece mi sembrava
straordinario è che di anno in anno
erano sempre di più dei firmatari di
questi cartelloni a partire e magari a
partire e cambiare 2 35 paesi e città di
residenza all'estero allora non sapevamo
ancora ma quello che succedeva nel
salotto di casa dei miei genitori era
perfettamente in tendenza con il resto
d'italia
infatti secondo l'istat sono 316 mila i
cittadini italiani sotto i 40 anni che
sono immigrati tra il 2000 e il 2010
e allora non sapevamo ancora ma se c'è
un mistero insondabile è proprio sapere
quanti italiani sono all'estero
infatti se i dati dell'istat e vi
sembravano già abbastanza elevati
sappiate che il centro altreitalie li ha
confrontati con le rilevazioni ufficiali
di alcuni paesi a forte immigrazione
italiana ricavandone delle cifre che
sono 35 più di 10 volte superiori per
esempio qui vedete il regno unito dove a
fronte di 32 mila e 800 italiani che
hanno richiesto il tesserino sanitario
inglese
secondo l'istat sono partite 7.400
persone ai corpi divertente l'australia
dove più di 18 mila persone hanno
chiesto un visto di lavoro di breve
periodo e per l'italia sono partiti in
meno di 1.400
tornando alle feste perché non voglio
allontanarmi troppo quello che è
successo e che una volta messa in
cantina e cartelloni ci è venuta la
curiosità dopo qualche anno di vedere
effettivamente dove eravamo quindi
abbiamo fatto una mappa dove qualcuno
tutti potevano mettere le proprie
bandierine quando il risultato è stato
questo ci siamo resi conto che si stava
materializzando sotto i nostri occhi
appunto in pochi metri quadrati età un
gruppo di amici così tanto numeroso un
network globale capace di avere punti in
tutto il mondo e adesso ce li abbiamo
punti in tutto il mondo perché abbiamo
aggiunto anche l'africa e l'australia
cosa è successo che quindi quando ci
siamo trovati di fronte a quell'immagine
ci siamo detti che volevamo farne
qualcosa ed è stato se non sbaglio
durante un viaggio mio e della mia amica
agnese che vive a monaco per andare a
trovare mio fratello che viveva a boston
e le nostre amiche chiara e valentina
che vivevano a washington e new york che
nell'estate del 2008 ci siamo detti che
quindi quell'anno non avremmo fatto solo
la festa ma avremmo fatto una giornata
di partecipazione e con una tecnica che
si chiama open space technology molto
bella che vi consiglia e si può dire che
quindi il 27 dicembre del 2008
il nostro gruppo di amici abbia subito
una modificazione genetica si sia
trasformato in expo rete di bolognese
nel mondo
le domande che ci volevamo porre erano
tremila quel giorno ne abbiamo scelta
una che avesse tornassi a bologna su
cosa vorrei lavorare cosa
vorrei trovare alla fine di una giornata
in cui parteciparono un centinaio di
persone alcune domande erano rimaste
senza risposta
la prima è ma torneremo la seconda era
ma quando i nostri genitori avranno
bisogno di noi saranno più anziani come
faremo altre però erano diventate delle
grandi certezze per esempio la prima era
che avevamo un grande desiderio di
trasformarci in nodi d'informazione cioè
di creare un dialogo bidirezionale tra
l'italia e il resto del mondo partendo
proprio da noi dalle nostre esperienze
come dire che se la prima immigrazione
rimandava a casa le famose rimesse cioè
soldi noi che siamo un altro tipo di
immigrazione
forse possiamo concentrarci su delle
rimesse 2.0 cioè il nostro capitale
culturale quello che tra l'altro il
nostro paese ha contribuito a formare
un'altra cosa che ci accomunava tutti
era tra ente che la retorica sui
cervelli in fuga ci faceva venire
l'orticaria
non so se avete notato ma funziona
sempre che chi parte o è un cervellone
un eroe che insegue il suo sogno è per
forza successo quindi oppure è un
individualista spietato che abbandona
suo paese che avrebbe tanto bisogno e
che tra l'altro ha speso tanti soldi per
farlo studiare mentre chi resta
tipicamente è uno che scende a
compromessi o un martire o appunto
qualcuno che chissà ha rinunciato ai
propri sogni ora niente di tutto questo
corrispondeva alle esperienze di vita
che avevamo noi eravamo amici qualcuno
era partito qualcuno no le ragioni erano
mille ma soprattutto le domande che ci
ponevamo sull'italia e sul mondo erano
le stesse erano le stesse e da lì
abbiamo capito anche che un altro
problema della retorica dei cervelli in
fuga che è alimentata da persone che
questa esperienza non l'hanno mai
vissuta e ci siamo resi conto che quindi
quello che mancava era forse una voce
collettiva da protagonisti su questo
tema
abbiamo scoperto perché fino a qui erano
cose territoriali vi potrei raccontare
per ore delle attività che ex boffa dal
2008 ad oggi e ma potete trovarle sul
sito ci siamo resi conto che non è tanto
facile capire quali sono i diritti ei
doveri di un cittadino italiano quando
emigra all'estero
sappiamo vagamente delle cose su un
registro a cui bisogna iscriversi
abbiamo il terrore della dichiarazione
dei redditi e siamo molto preoccupati
per l'assistenza sanitaria e quindi mi
permetto di segnalarvi questa guida che
è sul sito del ministero degli interni
perché per molti sarà una scoperta ci
sono tutte le informazioni che dovete
avere e vi segnalo anche che da pochi
giorni c'è anche una sulla colonnina
sinistra del sito del ministero degli
esteri
una serie di domande e risposte quindi
un formato diverso ma molto interessante
il problema appunto non era che ci
volevamo noi fermare a conoscere i
nostri diritti doveri perché avevamo
capito che quello che è interessante
anche fare cittadinanza attiva
e così abbiamo scoperto una cosa che
nessuno ci aveva mai detto
cioè che gli italiani all'estero possono
contare su tre forme di rappresentanza
una è rispetto al proprio territorio di
origine sono le famose consulte
regionali per le migrazioni una rispetto
al territorio di arrivo è lassù non
l'avete mai sentito dire i comites sono
i comitati per gli italiani all'estero e
sono per ogni circoscrizione consolare
quindi sono ovunque e il cgie loro
organo di secondo livello cioè che
rappresenta gli italiani a il mondo
rispetto al loro luogo di arrivo presso
il ministero degli affari esteri la
tratta forma di rappresentanza e li
farete più sereni perché la conoscete
senz'altro sono i parlamentari eletti
nella circoscrizione estera
questa è la conoscete ma in compenso le
altre due sono più antiche sono nate
negli anni 70 negli anni 80 e a
differenza dei parlamentari hanno una
base associativa e sono tenute da da
volontari allora perché sono importanti
queste forme di rappresentanza per prima
cosa perché se tanto tanto vi è sembrata
smart l'idea che abbiamo avuto in 30 a
bologna immaginatevi che questi sono
network di associazioni di italiani
tutto il mondo per seconda cosa perché
sono appena stati rinnovati i compiti
sono stati eletti ad aprile il cga a
settembre tra l'altro ne faccio parte e
la consulta per esempio quella
dell'emilia romagna sta proprio
rinnovandosi in questi giorni quindi al
momento perfetto per informarvi per
andarli a conoscere per stimolarli e
magari per pensare di candidarvi fa
cinque anni l'ultima ragione per cui
sono importanti e che hanno competenze
complementari per esempio se per caso
qualcuno di voi sta pensavo di
trasferirsi all'estero magari che ne so
a monaco piuttosto che a città del
messico piuttosto che a copenhagen
adesso sa che può rivolgersi al comites
di quel territorio per farsi aiutare
nell'inserimento per conoscere un po le
dinamiche del luogo di arrivo e quindi
insomma diciamo che svolgono una
funzione di mediatore culturale
se ci sono artisti o imprenditori tra di
voi che sono legati al territorio non
necessariamente regionale ma anche dei
comuni dell'emilia romagna di tutte le
altre regioni
magari sarà interessante per voi andare
a contattare la consulta per preparare
dei viaggi o per sollecitare le comunità
all'estero rispetto alle proprie
attività e magari creare progetti
appunto culturali economici per l'estero
queste sono forme di rappresentanza
importanti ma come dicevamo riguardano
sostanzialmente il nostro essere
cittadini italiani
ora se c'è un dato importante che non
bisogna dimenticare è che vabbè abbiamo
capito che le cifre sono un po vaghe
però questo chiama che come minimo gli
italiani all'estero sono 4 milioni e 600
mila 30 637.000 647 di questi 4 milioni
600 mila li avete capito
più della metà abitano risiedono dentro
l'unione europea significa che per due
milioni e mezzo di italiani
sostanzialmente i punti di riferimento
istituzionali sono il comune la regione
lo stato da cui si proviene il comune la
regione lo stato in cui si arriva e per
tutto l'unione europea e se vi sembra
già un po caotica la questione sappiate
che in realtà
sono 15 milioni i cittadini europei che
vivono in un paese dell'unione diverso
rispetto da quello di nascita quindi
stiamo allargando sempre di più lo
sguardo e la questione si fa complessa
allora mi permetto di segnalarvi di
nuovo una guida per i diritti e doveri e
soprattutto le forme di partecipazione
rispetto alla cittadinanza europea
qual è la questione che sostanzialmente
quello che abbiamo scoperto con l'adagio
non c'è lotta senza balotta funziona
anche quando ci si trasferisce cioè che
si possono incontrare altre ballotte si
può cominciare a voler fare altre lotte
per esempio qui mi vedete alle prese con
le reti di associazioni allora italiane
polacche spagnole e portoghesi a parigi
coordinati da 1 ng francese ci siamo
ritrovati nel 2014 per cercare di fare
capire ai cittadini comunitari che
potevano votare per le elezioni
municipali del loro paese del paese
della città di residenza e anche
scegliere per le elezioni europee votare
per i candidati del proprio paese di
origine o i candidati del proprio paese
di residenza e anche gli è successo
qualcosa di straordinario eravamo tutti
intenti a fare questo progetto e ci
siamo guardati attorno
abbiamo pensato che forse eravamo
l'unico coordinamento di comunità
europee su un territorio nel mondo e
quindi ci siamo inventati un nuovo
progetto che c'è stato finanziato dalla
regione il de france che la regione di
parigi e nel prossimo anno
trasformeremo questo coordinamento in
coordinamento permanente perché almeno
appunto chi è sul territorio possa avere
un'idea di cosa significa forse almeno
per noi essere l'europa dei popoli
avrete capito che mi piacciono i
cartelloni tra tutti quelli che abbiamo
scritto con questo gruppo di amici sono
poi diventati amici quello forse più
importante è proprio quello con la
domanda di tutte le domande quali europa
vogliamo è la risposta non la possiamo
delegare ad altri cioè le istituzioni la
burocrazia sono degli strumenti ma siamo
noi gli attori
di questa domanda e delle risposte
e questa risposta la dobbiamo trovare
proprio oggi cioè nella crisi della
grecia con l'arrivo dei migranti che tra
l'altro sono anche loro dei cittadini
mobili e queste sono delle sfide e che
non possiamo più rimandare
un'espressione che forse avete tutti
sentito dire è probabilmente utilizzato
è cittadino del mondo
se ci fate caso questa espressione
rinvia a un idea quella della libertà di
poter viaggiare in giro per il mondo con
una valigia e sentirsi a casa magari con
un volo low cost
ora questo magari ha più a che vedere
con la globalizzazione dei consumi ma
con la cittadinanza un poco meno e il
rischio è che se non sentiamo l'urgenza
di rispondere a queste domande
quello che succede che ci sentiamo
cittadini del mondo e ci risvegliamo
cittadini di nessun luogo oggi spero di
avervi mostrato tante vie diverse per
trovare la vostra strada quella che vi
parla di più per partecipare e spero
soprattutto che sia chiaro che questo
almeno per me è stato sempre l'occasione
di sperimentare tanto divertimento e con
tanti amici